التي يذهب اليها فقد تصل مخلفاته
الى حيث لا يرغب. فيتم فحصها
كالمنتجع. ولكنها ايضا امنة
ومؤمنة بجميع انواع الحماية. من
مجهزا بكل اشكال الامن لحمايته
الشخصية. كيم يملك الدولة
ملايين دولار? فضلا عن السفن
العملاقة فيمتلك كيم اسطولا
الامام والخلف لقطار الزعيم.
وبين القطار والاخر مسافة لا تقل
واخراج اسراره الصحية للعالم او
للاستخبارات العالمية. فيكتشفون
الامنية في معدات الاتصالات
والمعدات الطبية تجنبا لاي طارئ.
بنظام الامن العسكري. فيأتي
بالمقدمة قطار الاستكشاف الذي
الشخصية لفرض ثقتهم بانفسهم. لكن
لمجنون كوريا رأي اخر. وهنا تظهر
بمبالغ طائلة بعشرات الملايين من
الدولارات سنويا. ولا يأكل كيم
مع تحديثات بما يناسب العصر
الحديث. مجهزة بكل ما يلزم
لم يعلم بها شعب كوريا الشمالية
الا بعد ايام من بدايتها. طائرات
الحصول على المعلومات الداخلية.
وربما استحالة الوصول اليها. ولا
للرفاهية. وكذلك كل احتياطات
الامن والسلامة. كل ذلك لاجل
تستطيع الصحف المحلية ان تكتب
الا ما تسمع به الحكومة ولا مجال
للمعارضة. انه تكميم الافواه يا
اصدقائي. وابرز مثال على ذلك هي
دائما. ولا يعتبر كيم امن حمامه
الخاص امنا صحيا. بل امنا قوميا
الجيش والطائرات والمسيرات
والسفن. فحتى اوقات راحته
نقطة ضعف في المجنون بدون لكن
كيم يستخدم حمامه الخاص والمتنقل
برمتها. ولكن يجدر بنا ذكر
جزيرته الخاصة. فهي جزيرة فخمة
خوفا ايها المجنون? يخت باهظ
الثمن? هذا اليخت? ماركة برنس
يخت انترناشيونال? بنظام حماية
فائق القوة وبقيمة تقدر بسبعة
يركضون كالحمقى بجانب سيارة كيم.
وطائرة درونز التي تحوم وتستكشف
ولكن لديه قصور في انحاء البلاد.
ينتقل بينها بشكل حريص ومدروس.
الاسلحة الخاصة بالجيش. ليست فقط
للحروب. ولكن مسموح لكيم
عن ستين دقيقة. وتمتلئ القطارات
برجال الامن والمرافقين والمعدات
امان كيم الجوي. قطار خاص. عام
الفين وتسعة. كيم اسطول قطارات
حماية نفسه. لكن من يوصفون
بالجنون قد يقللون من حمايتهم
الطعام الا بعد فحصه وتذوقه جيدا
من الخبراء. فسلامة غذائه ركيزة
المدرعات تنقل الجنود ومضى كيم
بموكب مهيب لا يقل عن ثلاثين
جنود فيتنام يحرسون مدرعاته
اثناء مكوثه في احد الفنادق
الاعلام والصحف بشكل كلي من قبل
المجنون. وهناك صعوبة بالغة في
المنطقة وتراقب من الاعلى. وكان
كل ذلك لم يكفي. فقد جعل المجنون
اساسية لا يمكن ان يساوم فيها.
كل شخص له طريقته الخاصة في
للبلاد كلها. خبراء الطعام. كيم
يصرف الكثير على طعامه وشرابه
للغير او انها قد تصل لاعدائه.
فلو استخدم كم حمامات الاماكن
ومحصنة كالقلاع. وهي كثيرة
للتمويه وكثرة التنقل بينها.
فارهة ولكنها كلاسيكية بعض
الشيء. فهي صناعة سوفيتية قديمة
هناك. وعن حماية نتحدث. القصور
المهيبة والكثيرة فهي كبيرة جدا
فالمجنون لا يستقر في مكان واحد
حتى لا يكون عرضة للاغتيالات.
على الاعتراض? بالطبع لا.
الدبابات والمدرعات وجميع
متنقلا. فهو لا ينسى سلامته
الشخصية واسراره الصحية لتصل
لمجنون كوريا. وهل كم راحته?
حمام خاص. كم يمتلك مرحاضا
الاحزمة. لننطلق في رحلتنا عن
طرق حماية المجنون نفسه ضد
من يعدم الاشخاص لمجرد تقصير
بسيط في اداء العمل. من يعدم
القبضة الحديدية في بلاده. وصاحب
طرق الاعدامات الاغرب في العالم.
سيارة مع المدرعات والمصفحات.
فضلا عن اثني عشر فردا من الحرس
هكذا يرى المجنون انه في
التنقلات. ايكون ذلك حرصا ام
واستجمامه لا يترك كيم امنه
للصدفة والحظ. رفاهية امنة
يمشي في السكة ليتفقد الرحلة.
وتكون القطارات مقسمة ما بين
مكون من ست قطارات تحوي تسعين
عربة. لكنه يمشي بهذه القطارات
التصرف بجميع الممتلكات. وهكذا
تنص قوانين كيم. فهل يجرؤ احد
الكل سيسري عليه الاعدام اراد
كيم ؟ فكيف يحمي شخص ككمد جونج
الحرب الاوكرانية التي علم بها
القاصي والداني في هذا العالم.
ويا له من مجنون اثار جنون
العقلاء. لكن مهلا اذا كان كيم
مجنونا حقا. فكيف له ان يحمي
نفسه? انه لامر غريب حقا. له
وللجنون حدود. لكن زعيم كوريا
الشمالية لا حدود لجنونه. صاحب
في العالم. لكن لم يقدر احد ان
يسبب له اي مشكلة. نعم هو مجنون
الكثير من الاعداء في الداخل
والخارج. بل وتعاديه اقوى الدول
حتى لا يعلم مكانه احد. عن الحذر
الشديد نتحدث يا سادة. سيطرة على
في كوريا شمالية كل ما يمتلكه
الشعب هو ملك للمجنون. وله حق
اشتراكية وفي النظام الاشتراكي.
كل ما يمتلكه الشعب للدولة ولكن
اون نفسه من الاغتيالات؟ وكيف
يمضي حياته امنة؟ اربطوا
الاخطار. هيا بنا يا رفاق. كيم
جونج اون زعيم اشتراكي ودولته
استخدامها ان شاء وكيف شاء. ففي
زيارة للمجنون الى فيتنام استخدم
في حضرة كيم لن يحميك منصب ولن
تنفعك قرابة. فانت امام المجنون.
قوته يا سادة.
المقصر ايا كان. اكان من اقاربه
او اصحابه او حتى من العامة?